hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
february 14th ah it's the ladies day
2022
[Music]
um
shout out to all the ladies today this
is your second christmas
hanukkah kwanzaa
or whatever else you celebrate this is
this day is for the ladies
where all the men celebrate our
relationship with you
our relationship together
yet for some reason the financial burden
is all on us
[Music]
oh jesus christ you wouldn't believe
what my lovely wife just said to me i
had some friends over we watched the
game we're sitting outside we're smoking
sticks afterwards
and she cleaned up the kitchen
right and then you know as she should
no she cleans up the kitchen right where
they belong kidding
um
and she says to me afterward she just
goes like
she goes
she goes i did the whole you know
i cleaned up all the kitchen but blah
blah she goes
she goes tonight was your valentine's
day
can you [ __ ] believe that
you [ __ ] did some dishes and you
cleaned up and like that's what you did
for me
you know i mean she they did
that's what they used to do every
[ __ ] day and iron your shirt
unbelievable so i guess that was my
valentine day not to mention the other
night she has a wonderful friends over
and they were supposed to watch a movie
and they didn't you know women they
start [ __ ] talking
and they never stop and then down the
kitchen it's echoing upstairs we got the
kids sleeping oh my god she would have
raised holy hell if i did that i was
literally upstairs in bed i had made a
head sandwich
with two [ __ ] pillows and i was going
can you at least [ __ ] you know go to
the back room
she doesn't see it you know whatever do
i [ __ ] break her ovaries about that
no
no i do not no i do not
um
nah she's [ __ ] awesome but she's just
[ __ ] crack me up oh is that all you
had to do wash a couple of [ __ ]
spoons and a few dishes
happy valentine's day
thanks for flying out to east bum [ __ ]
every other weekend telling your [ __ ]
jokes
did i tell you lately that i love you
did i wash a saucer and a cup
i put them in the rack i did not dry
them
you came in afterwards and finished the
job
um
this is your valentine's day what the
[ __ ]
anyway let's get on to football
um
by valentine's day she puts up with me
all right and you know that's the truth
and i'm not saying this because i know
she's probably listening to this
uh
no it's true she does put up me and i am
a lot
i am a lot you know it all balances out
i do a lot and then i am a lot and it
negates it you know it's funny we we uh
so we're sitting outside we're smoking
cigars and you know the second you sit
down with your buddies to smoke your
cigars what's gonna happen your wife's
gonna come out and be like could you
come inside for a second
with that tone that makes everybody's
[ __ ] [ __ ] go like oh [ __ ] my
buddy's in trouble
so i come in and she goes uh
our daughter is coughing she has dust
all over and she's having problems
sleeping
she just came down and i look at my
daughter she has dust on the end of her
nose it's all on her sleeve and it's all
in her [ __ ] hair
and i'm like what the is there something
coming down from the ceiling i don't
know
i go go check the ceiling and she gives
me the look which means you go check the
ceiling so i go up there there's nothing
on the ceiling i'm looking at her
stuffed animals there's no problem
so then i go first 48 on my kid
and i'm like did you get out of bed
and she's like no
and i just cocked my head and i gave her
the [ __ ] you know the rock
put the eyebrow up and i just gave her
the look
and she goes i go did you go over the
window
you know because he was sitting in the
backyard and she was like yes
so i walk over to the curtains that came
with the house
and i just go on the inside of the
curtains and i drag my fingers down and
it's the exact same dust
i'm like there you go
that's what it was right so now my wife
has to give a shout by the way i gave my
daughter the bath
have i told you lately that i did [ __ ]
too
did i rub it in your face and say i'm
not taking you out to dinner now cause i
gave our kid a bath and i put her to bed
i've done my [ __ ] for the year i did
not do that
i walked in there like sherlock and
holmes figured it out
figured it out in two [ __ ] seconds
you know it's soft
my daughter to take another bath but you
know
whatever [ __ ] happened so
when i go back downstairs so but anyway
uh first and foremost
congratulations to your
los angeles rams
super bowl
56
nfl champions for the year 2
2021 in the 2022 whatever you say uh
sean mcvay
sean mcvay no more naysayers
the wonder kid oh you know we went to a
super bowl but he lost you know
i don't know i was doubting the guy i
was going you know i don't know about
this guy
he's a good-looking guy he's young and
everybody got excited i don't know
i played pop warner football in third
grade for a couple weeks before my dad
saw the cte coming and he pulled me out
very smart move on his behalf thank you
very much to him
um
he also probably saw the way i was
running but you know the reason why i
was running that way is because he
bought me an adult-sized cup and i was
in [ __ ] third grade and i swear to
god not only could you not [ __ ] kick
me in the balls i wouldn't feel it you
also couldn't give me a roundhouse to my
hips the [ __ ] thing was so big
i wouldn't have felt anything but i was
also running down the field like i've
been riding horses
you know i want to play wide receiver
and i end up [ __ ] playing the
offensive line
um this kid's got no wheels
[ __ ] that's what they said everybody
remember the first day of practice
everybody run down to that fence and
come back and i'm [ __ ] waddling and
there's [ __ ] kids i was beating in
outdoor recess i'm like why the [ __ ] are
they running so goddamn fast this helmet
must be heavy
and i kept the cup
uh the jog strap because i wanted to
[ __ ] play
and that dream never happened it just
sat in my underwear drawer and then one
day i was in high school
and i was looking at the thing
and i'm like wait a minute and i [ __ ]
put it on i'm like jesus christ he
bought me the adult size
[Laughter]
but because of that [ __ ] up
other avenues opened
and now i tell [ __ ] jokes and [ __ ]
from here to albuquerque up to [ __ ]
uh duluth
over to [ __ ] saskatchewan
out to perth i've been all over i've
been everywhere man telling my [ __ ]
[ __ ] jokes so um anyway
congratulations
to sean mcvay
living up to the hype
he coached a great game it was a [ __ ]
great game uh i don't want to hear any
[ __ ] about the officiating
because that [ __ ] wide receiver on
the bengals that was one of those
slickest [ __ ] face masks you ever i
can't get mad at that ref for missing it
he gave him the old what's that over
there huh he [ __ ] like he tapped him
on the shoulder and he helped his head
go around so they got a touchdown there
so i can't get mad at that ticky tack
first hold call that they called at the
end of the [ __ ] game
um and then those other ones that they
called the bengals were doing it i was a
joe burrow bengals guy and all of that
condolences to the bengal fans um
i'll get to you guys in a second i got
to give la props you won the [ __ ]
title with the goddamn [ __ ]
lakers
you wanna uh
title with the dodgers as i've always
liked the dodgers because the red sox
could never beat the [ __ ] yankees
back in the day
and so i rooted for them in 70 uh 77 78
and an 81
and 88 i always rooted for him i love
tommy lasorda and i also love the
dodgers i always you know dusty baker
run say
davey lopes
i loved all of them steve
yeager
um
bill russell i loved all of those guys
um
was it also bill russell bill russell
the celtic but was also one of them
there a pitcher bill uh bill russell
fernando
valenzuela um
kirk gibson all of them so you won that
and there's one other one you you won
something you won a couple of cups
they won the stanley cup a world series
a super bowl in an nba title
you know i know they have two [ __ ]
nba teams but it's the [ __ ] clippers
you know
they didn't win in san diego they ever
won here either
um but anyway um
home teams of the nfl when they play at
all but the super bowl are undefeated
two years in a row
um congratulations to matthew stafford
all of those years
playing for the detroit lions the only
guy who went in and got out alive since
[ __ ] bobby lane
um
comes here and wins
a [ __ ] nfl title and and made that
trade
the jared goff trade it just
they they did it their defense played
great
um
they held those front four for a while
and then it just then they just became a
[ __ ] problem
and um congratulations to them it was a
great [ __ ] game i knew it was going
to be a good game some people were
saying a blowout
the rams and all of that it was a really
fascinating game where there was like a
moment there
other than odell beckham's uh yards
where it was just like uh
it's like is a running back gonna have
the most [ __ ]
receiving yards in this game and i gotta
tell you how many [ __ ] how many
[ __ ] times
were they gonna get beat on that day the
third check down with that [ __ ]
running back just standing out there for
the screen pass that was that was money
for them all day long
um
just an amazing game and condolences to
uh cincinnati bengal fans
uh here is the upside
your defense played good enough
joe burrow i mean you got the
quarterback of the future you got a
golden boy there
under center um you got the running back
you got the receiving cord gee what will
you be drafting next year what are you
moving up in the draft for
um that offensive line man it just
you know granted they were going up
against the best but they also delivered
you know against the chiefs after um
the embarrassing performance against the
titans
um
but it was just it was just a [ __ ]
great great game and um
there's nothing more to say and i am a
bengals fan now
i'm always a patriots fan but i'm
rooting for the bengals because i love
their history and i was really hoping
that the era that paul brown one of the
few errors he ever made make letting
bill walsh go
and bringing the offense that he created
out to the 49ers that then became known
as the west coast offense it was
developed
in cincinnati and i was really hoping
that they were finally going to get
their uh their ring but i think that
they have one in the future they just
all they need is an offensive line they
got everything else they got the coach
they got the owner
obviously the great fan base and all
that type of [ __ ] um and uh it was just
an awesome awesome awesome game and uh
we had a great super bowl party
impromptu because it was a couple guys
buddies of mine came into town what
happened they were trying to get tickets
and everything and it was like
[ __ ] six grand
for nosebleeds or you could just stay at
home on a flat screen tv hit pause and
all of that [ __ ]
um
i missed the halftime show but i saw a
little bit of uh dr dre and snoop and it
and like
la really did the halftime show right
and i think it's so awesome
that all of those legends uh
from la
and the amount of [ __ ] they got when
they first came out
snoop nwa all of those guys it was so
great that they got to go up there and
[ __ ]
do what they should have been able to do
a long time ago uh so that was great too
it's just a [ __ ] great game
uh all the way around and um
we ended up having this great super bowl
party we had squares going
we had some food and old billy oh billy
[ __ ] shakespeare i got an acting gig
coming up so
i've been uh dropping weight i didn't
have any super bowl food whatsoever
i have my special
uh [ __ ] freckles meals and i ate
those things i actually at one point
almost gave in but instead i had an
apple
and some peanuts
my one sin was i had one of those mini
root beers
afterward when i was uh smoking a couple
of cigars
with my buddies and um
it was great everybody had a good time
nia bet some squares so she was in and
on the game and everything and at the
end of the night uh
everybody was laughing at my kids just
running around their pajamas chasing
each other
and uh you know
i was really proud of my kids man
they're just
social
they're smiling they're happy they they
know that they're loved
and you know i broke the curse you know
[Laughter]
of uh you know the shutdown emotion
that has trickled down through uh you
know through generations
not even i'm not [ __ ] on my family
tree i'm just saying you know how i grew
up versus how they're growing up so it's
good and it made me feel good that i
waited as long as i did to become a dad
so i worked out enough of my [ __ ]
that um
see my kids running around being happy
and not like
all freaked out by comp company and [ __ ]
my my daughter was a little shy at first
but then she was
she was fine i'll tell you what was cool
this week is um
i got my daughter out on the skateboard
for the first time
had her all padded up and everything and
uh
and she just just [ __ ] took right to
it
she loved she was a little nervous at
first i had to hold her hand and
everything and by the end she'd get
herself going and then she would let go
and she would [ __ ] crouch down a
little bit like she saw she's been
watching kids
skateboard on uh on youtube and
everything so she was crouching down
doing the whole thing she had big ear to
ear smile
and um
you know she was uh
you know telling my wife to come out on
the porch and watch her and my son was
yelling down at her and stuff and
everybody was clapping when she was
skateboarding and stuff and we came up
the driveway i said to her
i was going you know i'm so proud of you
doing great you know he did great and
all that stuff right so
i said to uh
i said to her when she was being shy
um
i said you know i showed everybody uh
yes the skateboard because i had to take
a video the first time she was going
right
i was like i showed everybody your video
and how great you did and she said and
she said to me she goes did they all
watch it and were they proud of me
[Laughter]
she actually spoke about herself in the
third person it was hilarious
so um
anyway and i found out they got a bunch
of skateboard parks out here so that's
what i'm going to be doing i'm not
working on this uh this movie
is taking her to those things so anyway
i am uh i am locked in
today was the it was the big
was the big um
today was the big the big test
today was the big test with the uh with
the super bowl
[ __ ] party and all of that [ __ ] where
i was just like am i gonna be able to
lay off
oh man
what i laid off oh
did this [ __ ]
buffalo something dip
there were wings
they had the mozzarella sticks my
favorite
takes me back to the east coast even
though they don't [ __ ] make them
right out here
um what else did we have
um
what else didn't i eat oh there was
chips
there was desserts there was booze
oh there was booze
all my old friends were there
the bourbon the beers
the brown the clear was all going
everybody was having a good time and all
[ __ ]
[ __ ] johnny appleseed was sitting
there eating a [ __ ] apple and peanuts
what are you gonna do um it is what it
is i hate it at night but i like it in
the morning when you wake up
you know you wake up your stomach's a
little flatter
you start looking in the mirror i still
got it right yeah
if i wanted to
i could make the taxi squad or one of
these [ __ ] teams speaking of taxi
squads how the [ __ ]
my one criticism of the bengals how the
[ __ ]
do you take a penalty you're not even in
the game
you're not even wearing a uniform
i missed that because i was giving my
daughter a bath and [ __ ] i missed the
very very end of the half
i guess this guy ran out on the field to
celebrate interception jesus [ __ ]
christ
if that guy was still on the sidelines
for the rest of the game i don't know
i don't know what i have to say about my
my new adopted franchise the cincinnati
bengals
it was the tampa bay buccaneers for
obvious reasons with tom brady and
gronkowski and all of them but now that
uh the great tom brady has retired
um
you know
i got to go i got to go with the bank
i'm going to be i'm rooting for the pats
and i'm rooting for the bengals and i'm
hoping uh
you know mack jones keeps improving and
all of that type of stuff and then we
have great showdowns with them
you know
that the joe burrow mac jones thing
becomes what the great peyton manning
tom brady battles were
um either way
if just as a football fan it's great to
see you know
another what looks like great
quarterback coming along
um
you know it's great for the game
it's great for the game you got to have
the great field generals
the patrick mahomes all of them to step
in when the drew breezes retire speaking
of retiring as a bruins fan
i got to give a shout out to the great
tucarask
calling it quits at 34.
um
not [ __ ] over the bruins realizing he
couldn't compete at a level that he
wanted to compete at and uh
like a gentleman
class act that he was the whole time he
was with the bruins helped us win a
stanley cup in 2011
breaking a 40-year drought
um
just the way the guy conducted himself
and all those deep playoff runs that we
had never would have had it without that
guy that guy stood on his head so many
times for us
uh another brewing great
retiring my god
so the only two guys left are marshawn
and uh
patrice bergeron
uh by the way do you guys see marshawn
how [ __ ] hilarious is that guy i
swear to god that guy could have been a
stand-up comedian he would have been a
great one
just his instincts and how much he loves
pissing off a crowd and just annoying
people he'd be [ __ ] amazing
we're playing the penguins we lost but
at one point the penguins goalie
he had a puck on his on his his big dumb
goalie stick and i guess he was going to
take it off and flick it into the crowd
i retweeted it it's on my uh my uh
my twitter feed
steve byrne big penguins fan great
comedian sent it to me
and uh the guy the goalie i guess he saw
a penguins fan he was gonna flip it into
the crowd and marshawn skated by
just slapped the puck down and [ __ ]
took it away from him and then threw the
puck he's [ __ ] hilarious
[ __ ]
hilarious
and somebody on twitter wrote to me
said i would rather watch five hours
of pre-game super bowl chatter than
watch
brad marchand play hockey and i just was
[ __ ] laughing i'm like that's how
good he is at his job
he's so good at his job
he even gets under the skin of people
who aren't even playing in the [ __ ]
game i mean
it's a [ __ ] genius
[ __ ] genius what that guy does
um
and then plus whenever he does his
[ __ ] [ __ ] i love when penguin
fans get all upset
uh
you know
saying he's dirty and blah blah and i
always have i can always end that
argument i just go he's dirty you have
alf samuelson
in your ring of honor
you can say a lot of things about alf
samuelson honor should never be anywhere
near that guy's [ __ ] name and you
have him there you had matt cook on your
team
just career enders what the [ __ ] is
marsh john doing
huh getting under your skin licking
faces and slapping pucks down i don't
want to [ __ ] hear it
goes low every once in a while
i mean what's he supposed to do he is
low
is he supposed to hit you high
um
i'm a little biased i [ __ ] love that
guy uh so anyway shout out to him
this is old billy good mood i'm in a
good mood
i'm in a great [ __ ] mood
dropping goddamn
[ __ ] all the sins i committed
in my uh
during my quarantine i had this period i
was going through man where i would just
it was the best
but it was stupid
i was [ __ ] you know
me and my wife
these ice cream sandwiches that we loved
it bad enough it was an ice cream
sandwich it was ice cream in with like
two chocolate chip cookies for the
sandwich
and that just became like our go-to
you know
like i wouldn't go to the grocery store
and just buy two i would stock up like i
do with cigars
so i'd have some right
and we just every night
we'd be like we're not having an ice
cream sandwich and then it'd be like
you want an ice cream sandwich and she
look at me with her cute face and be
like yes
and uh that's what i was doing at my age
you can't do that and uh you know the
great thing the funny thing about
putting on weight is you just don't
notice
you know it's like you don't notice
yourself aging and because you look at
yourself in the mirror every day so you
just don't notice it until somebody
sends a picture from
three four years ago you're like [ __ ]
what happened
what the [ __ ] happened that's the same
thing with weight
you don't think anything's happening
you're like i'm fine look at me am i
right you know you do that thing where
you sort of push down your shirt yeah
i'm all right look at me i'm okay
it's coming down it's not that bad right
and your wife loves you she's like no
you look good you look good
and then one day
you have some sort of event where you
gotta [ __ ] wear a suit you pull out
those that pair of slacks you always put
on
it doesn't matter if somebody's getting
christened or somebody [ __ ] died or
uh you got a court appearance you pull
out your slacks
from the back of the closet and they got
that that little fastener thing
whatever the [ __ ] that's supposed to be
you know of course it's made out of the
weakest metal ever so if you can even
get it shut it fails on you
i put on my [ __ ] gray pants
and like i couldn't even get him to
touch
and i was like you got what the [ __ ] did
i do
and i got on the scale and i was a buck
90. i'm supposed to be about 170 to 168
once
172.
it's my wheelhouse right
um
when i'm doing my little soliloquies
here in the [ __ ] uh acting [ __ ] right
and i went to go put those [ __ ]
things on and i swear to god i was like
are these are these my son's pants like
what the [ __ ] happened
so um
and also i went to a wardrobe fitting
too
and i'm putting the [ __ ] pants on i'm
like these are 34s
and like the wardrobe person's like
making that face like yeah yeah they are
it's like i'm still in the 30s but i
don't think i'm on this side of 35. you
got [ __ ] 36 you got the one of the
worst things that happened for this
country
and i think
people in general
okay okay if i was a dictator
you know what i would get rid of i would
get rid of jeans with those elastic
sweatpants [ __ ] waist things because
you can be 38 and fit into a 34
and you're walking around i was at 32 in
high school i'm only that's all right
two inches up no you're a [ __ ] 38.
i think i got to go back to wearing the
original [ __ ] levi jeans the ones
that cowboys wore around the campfire
when we stole this country
um i just say that just to get we're
still wait wait take the country what
are you talking about we did
we did
we acted like we were friends
okay
the indians believed us they taught us
how to live outside
and that was it
all right going back they should have
let us die
um
how do you live out here i don't know
you know you just gotta well you'll
figure it out
that's what they should hey one of my
favorite expressions
and this is so true in world history no
good deed goes unpunished
i don't know how to say that native
american but um
i'm guessing that that [ __ ]
expression did not exist amongst them
because they what do they teach us how
to
farm and all of that [ __ ]
bad move
bad move that that was
that was the human being equivalent
of cincinnati
university of winning the toss and
giving the ball to alabama
with a heisman trophy quarterback you're
just looking back
should have taken the ball
um
i really just oversimplified genocide
didn't i yes i did
yes i did but you do not come on this
podcast
to listen to intellect do you
you come on this podcast to feel better
about yourselves
you know i thought i was a dumb guy i
don't think i'm that bad i'm basically
mentally
um the same version of like uh the
elastic waistband on a [ __ ] pair of
jeans
all right with that let's do some live
reads here
live reads for valentine's day uh it's
for the ladies
it's celebrating our relationship
with men's money there's no feminist on
[ __ ] valentine's day is there
um
i would love to yell that
at a feminist rally
at the chick with the bull horn
hey hey sweetheart
hey honey
what did you call me i called you
sweetheart and then i called you honey
this is typical can i just say this
and then you know this is a fantasy so
she actually shuts up like you're gonna
shut up a feminist with a [ __ ]
bullhorn but in this fantasy she shuts
up
and i say hey sweetheart
not for nothing
who pays for your valentine's day meal
every year
and she be in the bullhorn like what
what did i i didn't hear what you said
you heard me who pays for your
valentine's day meal
and that's a slippery slope because if
she answers who pays the child support
who goes up on the [ __ ] roof and
risks a broken neck every time a ball
goes up there
huh
well it's a fantasy at that point she
goes you know what you're absolutely
right ladies maybe we need to tone this
down a little bit
um and actually honor steak in a [ __ ]
day does anybody know the date because i
don't all right
policy genius everybody
policy genius
are you home
are you sorry are your
are your home and auto policies almost
up for renewal we're newer renewal uh
let policy genius look for a lower rate
for you by uh comparing top insurers
from progressive
to all state
this is how it works in case you were
like well how does that work policy
genius is your one-stop shop to find and
buy the insurance you need
click the link in the description
or head to
policygenius.com if you're dumb like me
genius is spelled g-e-n-i-u-s
not how kanye west spells it policy
genius.com
and answer a few questions policy genius
oh that root beer is making me hiccup
here uh policy genius will show you
price estimates for policies that fit
your search and help you uh understand
your options
uh the policy genius team can look for
ways to save you more money and if they
find a better rate than what you're
paying for now uh what you're paying now
they'll switch it over for free
policy genius has saved customers an
average of
350 dollars per year on home
insurance
that's 350 dollars that you could spend
on your wife
or girlfriend on valentine's day and not
on yourself
unless you're buying this steak
on steak and your own hand job day when
you rub one out afterwards
uh number five the policy genius team
works for you not the insurance company
you can trust them to offer unbiased
help
and advocate for you at every step until
you're covered since 2014
policy genius has helped over 30 million
people shop for insurance and play and
placed over 120 billion in coverages
uh
headthepolicygenius.com to get your free
uh can get your free home and auto
insurance quotes and see how much you
could you could save
all right oh look who it is everybody i
love doing this read look who it is it's
all zip
[Music]
i'll tell you he's using zip recruiter
right now that [ __ ] jackass on the
bengals who ran out in the field
he's not gonna have that on his [ __ ]
resume is he
according to the latest research 90
of employers plan to make
uh in
enhancing the employee experience a top
priority
in
two 2022 all a happy workplace is key to
attracting and keeping great employees
and if you need to add more employees to
your team there's zip
and right now you can try zip recruiter
for free at ziprecruiter.com
burr b-u-r-r zip recruiter uses its
powerful technology to find and match
the right candidates up with your job
then it proactively
presents these candidates to you they
don't just get the candidates and sit on
their
damn hands
they get the candidates right to you
yeah you know what [ __ ] the bengals
they should use that for their offensive
line you can easily review these
recommended candidates and invite your
top choices to apply for your job which
encourages them to apply faster find the
right employees for your workplace with
ziprecruiter try it for free at this
exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com that zip
dot com slash burr spell out burp
b-u-r-r
sip recruiter the smartest way to hire
oh we got one more here it's indochito
indochino this year let indochino take
care of your 2022
style edit you can customize everything
from from suits and shirts to chinos and
bomber jackets at prices more affordable
than you might expect
indochito offers completely custom
fitted suits
geez i could use one you got a fat suit
for me can i buy the one eddie murphy
wore in the clumps
uh fitted suits shirts casual wear and
more at surprisingly affordable prices
get a wardrobe personalized to your
style and taste without spending a
fortune every piece is made to your
exact measurements and you can customize
every detail man choose everything
everything from your suit including the
fabric the repel monogram and you can
have a statement lining
you meet a chick in a bar
what's your deal what do you like you
just open up your coat you see that
lining sweetheart that's what you're
signing up for that's right that's right
walk away you can't handle a man like me
um anyway and casual okay indochino
offers prices more affordable than you
might expect indochino offers completely
custom fitted suits shirts casual wear
and more at surprisingly affordable
prices get a wardrobe personalized to
your style and taste without spending a
fortune every piece is made to your
exact measurements and you can customize
every goddamn detail
i already read this
the best part indochino suits start from
just 429. and shirts started from seven
and nine dollars for all customized
that's all customizations included give
yourself a style edit that sets the tone
for the rest of the year with indochino
get a fifth get 50 bucks off any
purchase of 3.99
or more by using promo code burr at
indochino.com that's 50 off a purchase
of 399 or more at ind och
dot
ino.com
promo code bur b u
double r all right in with that with
that
um
let's let's let's do a little bit of
advice
um all right here we go cigars
cigars [ __ ]
cigars [ __ ] or get off the pot
uh hey oh billy blowing smoke
you nailed down the alcohol sobriety so
congrats but hey you probably have a
combined 27 hours of podcast time over
the past 10 years talking about quitting
cigars it's like hearing the battered
woman explain for years and years how
it's hard how hard it is to leave just
do it or shut up about it already
hey look you know it took me a long time
to get where i'm at i'm working my [ __ ]
out
uh
dude you should have your own tv show
it's scared straight meets therapy meets
dr phil
um oh and i have tickets to see you soon
on your current tour so see you then
[ __ ] oh i'm out
all right
well whatever you know it's gonna take
me a while to quit i love them
i love them i love them as much as i
picked the bengals and they got four
points
um
all right yeah i know i am i am i keep
saying i'm gonna do it but here's the
thing i got a movie coming up so i won't
i won't smoke for like [ __ ] six weeks
and then i'll have it under control and
i'll be fine um
i almost have them out of my house i
keep having people over what am i
supposed to do what the [ __ ] am i
supposed to do i got to be a host right
um these are all weak excuses you're
right he's nice to me sometimes
after he hits me he says he's sorry
you're right
you're right you know so i gotta be if
i'm gonna be totally honest here
i knew that that right there i knew that
email was coming
um
i deserve it i take full responsibility
i sound like the guy with the flip-flops
right now probably talking to the media
tell me that guy didn't shower quick and
get the [ __ ] out of the goddamn arena
um
yeah you're right you're right i needed
that i needed that nice slap in the face
you know
why not hey join the [ __ ] crowd
you know evidently i just got my [ __ ]
valentine's day gift cause my wife
walked just washed a couple of dishes
oh i got to get it back on the podcast
again oh i'm going to get oh i'm going
to give her a couple a couple of
a couple of ideas i'm going to float
across the table um
russia and landmass we're actually going
out to dinner
on valentine's day which is funny to me
so i'm gonna be sitting there the whole
time at dinner i'm just gonna be going
like just just something clear here this
isn't for me
this isn't for me my you know
this dinner is not for me okay
am i allowed to eat
uh russia and land mass
coming from russia everybody russia and
landmass or maybe just somebody going to
tell me about russia who doesn't live
there hey billy big belly oh i love the
fat shaman i love the fat shaming and
now cigar shaming you're making me a
better more skinnier person everybody
um during your nato topic you mentioned
the russian land grab
and them not needing any more land they
are huge but you should check out
thetruesize.com because maps have to be
transcribed onto flat paper
the size of countries is largely
misrepresented if you're going to
[ __ ] sit here and tell me that going
from asia into another continent is not
a big
country if you're going to sit there and
argue and say a lot of their land isn't
used
because it's mountainous and freezing
[ __ ] cold uh i got an answer for that
global warming
they should just chill out and become
really [ __ ] cool
you know they should you know pretty
soon they're going to be growing weed in
[ __ ] siberia i think they're going to
be all right
anyway the site lets you drag the
selected countries to compare it to the
other countries for example mexico is
way larger than it appears when you move
it
up to the u.s location on the globe
in any case check out and you'll see
russia is actually about the size of the
usa when you include alaska
okay
i knew i shouldn't be afraid of these
guys thanks for everything you do can't
wait to see you in washington this well
so then what are you saying then
what is your point
so the u.s still be doing land grabs
then
because we're only as big as russia who
is as big as us we both need to stop
doing this [ __ ]
um thanks for everything you do can't
wait to see you in
walla walla washington in this may it's
not walla washington
um surprising my best friend
surprising my best friend with tickets
for his birthday
so don't get the rona
uh well i got the shots man when i had
it i didn't even know i had it
um
bank robbery story
i absolutely love this
that people you know something by the
way the person talking about the maps
i've seen that [ __ ] before like people
are trying to show how big um
africa is and they put all these
countries in there i don't bel they put
the united states in there we we barely
took up the top of the map
and uh
i don't remember russia being in there
they put china in there
um
whatever what do you guys want what do
you [ __ ] hit me with geography [ __ ]
for just because i've been to a bunch of
places didn't mean i learned anything
um bank robbery story
oh my god
hey billy raddish taint
god damn it
do you guys ever run out of ginger jokes
i mean this is [ __ ] amazing i've been
doing this podcast
since 2007 you [ __ ] every time
i think we're out of vegetables we're
out of [ __ ] all these different
things you can call me my god
carrots radishes i mean it's just it
just never stops
we're not even up to the top of the
fridge we're still in the crisper
um
you know it's funny i have a bright
orange [ __ ] refrigerator
in my office too i keep it real
bank robbery story hey billy radish tank
i got a bank robbery store story for
your chalky powdered donut ass
this guy's just killing me with the food
references here
uh i used to manage the teller line who
would have thought that this was going
to take off this is [ __ ] great
i want to hear from tellers and all the
dumb ways people tried to rob your
[ __ ] bank
banks
um you'd think that this would trend
more you know what i mean somebody came
in to rob a bank and it didn't [ __ ]
work um
wait a minute did all the bank robbers
just kind of go into like identity theft
they kind of do it on like the internet
on the internet now right
anyway i used to manage the teller line
at one of the branches of a national
bank
uh the one with the lawsuit
which one
um one day this guy with sunglasses and
a and basketball hat comes into the
lobby and asked to see the manager
like some shitty heist movie the manager
brings him into his office 15 minutes
later the manager escorts the guy to a
female teller and said this man needs 25
thousand dollars
the teller goes yes sir do you have a
debit card
the manager interrupts and says no just
give it to him
the teller nods and starts counting the
money
shaking
the guy begins to laugh at her
tears starts streaming down her face i'm
assuming it was the bank robber
tears starts streaming down her face i
immediately go back to the back and
start hitting the silent alarms and
telling the tellers at the drive up that
we're being robbed i go back to the
front to tell the tellers what's
happening when the phone rings before i
can get it another teller who was known
as the dumb [ __ ] of the branch
picks it up
hello
what
we're not being robbed
no everything's okay
[Laughter]
imagine the person was talking real loud
too oh no the security department
checking on us
it's the security department checking on
us i'm behind him saying hang up the
phone hang up the phone he turns to me
and goes no
this guy says we're being rubbed
the guy robbing us is 10 feet from us i
finally get the dumb [ __ ] to give me the
phone and i answer in the back and
explain the robber leaves with the money
the manager says the guy had a gun
he said he's going to shoot everyone in
here if we didn't give him the money i
asked the female teller if she put the
tracker in with the cash she said she
did
oh god the cops come and ask us
questions and leave we're all waiting
around for hours the cop comes back the
cops come back with a bag of cash and
two receipts saying
they found the robber and a
jack-in-the-box down the street oh god
so who was dumber
one receipt was for a was for was for
cab fare
and the other was for a jumbo jack with
extra large fries and a coke
the rest of the money was in the bag
thank you i gotta tell you if you're
gonna go to jail
i mean that's one of the best ways to
get caught as far as like you just had a
nice [ __ ]
jumbo jack and extra large and a coke
that sounds that's almost at this point
being on a diet worth doing a little
time for
uh thanks for all the years of laughs
and good times it means a lot truly go
[ __ ] yourself another bank robbery story
tellers
please i got three of them two more
coming here please
for the love of comedy keep [ __ ]
writing these in did you guys ever see
the one where the [ __ ] idiot was
standing in line
to rob the bank
he walks in and he takes out like
whipped cream or shaving cream and
sprays it all over his face and then
stands in line
i believe it was on america's dumbest
criminals i believe
and he's standing there and it's they
immediately hit the alarms
it's melting off of his face and when he
walks up to the teller the [ __ ] cops
show up
what a [ __ ] idiot
sir can you clean that off your face for
your mug shot please
all right bank robbery story
dear mr burr finally
a little respect on this podcast love
the podcast this person says
so
back in the late 90s i was living in
tampa
for college and worked at a bank near
busch gardens what a great place to go
to college tampa huh
[ __ ] all the hot chicks walking
around all the titty bars i mean you're
not studying
um
college is just to delay
the rest of your miserable life so go
have a good [ __ ] time
unless you're going after a dream other
than that if you just picked a [ __ ]
major go to go to college in tampa at
least you'll have those memories um
jesus that was negative
sorry now so back in the uh late 90s i
was living in tampa for college and
worked at a bank near busch gardens
which you know in tampa that might be
the name of a [ __ ] strip club
i don't like the landing strip come on
down to busch gardens
wall-to-wall pubes um so after opening
one morning a guy came in with his
t-shirt
pulled over his head
think beefus doing corn holio
there's a great reference
i am called julio i need tiki for my
bunghole um he walked up to the teller
next to me and yelled
give me hundreds and fifties
she just froze and said what
he had a tire iron and one hand
he came in to rob the bank like he was
going to clean up the neighborhood
he had a tire iron in one hand and kept
using the other to hold open the neck
hole
to see out of it it kept closing up
because he was shaking so bad
oh this poor bastard
i said i think he wants your larger
bills but this dumbass doesn't see this
bulletproof glass
i started laughing
oh my god you just took but you took a
gamble they didn't have anything else
the guy took the iron
and hit the glass and didn't even
scratch it
he ran outside with nothing
still attempting to hold the neck hole
of his shirt open
my manager was pissed but i said he
wasn't my in my teller window so
technically
i didn't not cooperate with his with the
demands
dude you got a [ __ ] law degree in
your future man you should become a
lawyer
um anyway
a detective came in with two fbi agents
and they were watching the video
they called me in when they saw me
laughing on the video and asked
what was said
they laughed when i told them
i got to get some fbi agents
any fbi agent you want to come in just
say you work for a certain service and i
want to hear all your dumb [ __ ]
uh criminal stories um i got transferred
to a different branch a month later
and that one didn't have glass in the
lobby
i'm sure a a [ __ ] you planned by the
manager absolutely
they wanted you to get your mind right
now this guy thinks he's all bulletproof
behind the glass we're gonna send him to
a [ __ ]
our first bank from 1860 that we never
[ __ ] did a remodel on anyway p.s now
i'm a detective i was gonna say
i knew you had something beyond this job
and your future i think of that day
every time i go to a bank robbery come
back to south florida
soon wow
wow you got balls man
you got balls
i mean yeah just [ __ ] give them the
money you put the [ __ ]
tracker in there and then you know go
eat your brown bag lunch and be happy
nothing happened to you
but thank god you didn't or else you
know i'd have nothing to talk about
during this part of the podcast
jesus christ the dumb [ __ ] doesn't know
what did you say to him
i think he wants your larger bills but
this dumbass doesn't see the bulletproof
glass
well i guess once you have a [ __ ]
t-shirt over your goddamn head that's
probably a good
good indication he doesn't have a gun
all right funny
quote robbery story
uh
yeah this this goes straight across if
you own a store
if somebody tried to mug you or whatever
i want to hear these ones um all right
funny robbery story hey hey billy bear
back in it burr
so i used to work in a pizza place i
really wish you said parlor for my
accent a pizza parlor
uh that was very busy that was a very
busy spot
after the bar let out
because uh we had huge slices
and we're open until 4am well absolutely
every town
has the big slice of pizza back on the
east coast you got to have it
we used to have this great place in
boston
one of the it was a great slice of pizza
too it was basically a double wide
slice of pizza it was this bar called
dominic's it was right across from the
legendary knicks comedy stop where i
started 30 years ago on march 2nd
and uh one of the big thrills in my life
was when i got invited over there to
hang out
and i got to hang out with the late
great
kevin knox
frank santarelli don gavin they were all
there all the [ __ ] legends and they'd
be over there having a couple of pops
and all you had to do is as a new comic
was shut the [ __ ] up buy a round
and you get to hear some of the greatest
stand-up comedy stories ever and right
next to the to the bar was a window it
was a pizza place that was part of it
and at the end of the night
after you had a bunch of [ __ ] drinks
and you needed to air quote sober up
that was back when we thought if you had
a double slice of pizza you could
actually drive a car 60 70 miles an hour
down the [ __ ]
southeast expressway through the central
lottery
and you'd go over there and it was just
the [ __ ] best and it was just a bunch
of drunk people drunk guys drunk chicks
standing out there folding these slices
and shoving it down our [ __ ] pie
holes
oh that was one of the saddest days ever
now there's a w hotel there
a soulless
w hotel
uh it's so awful it's just so awful what
corporations do to the vibes of towns
they just kill the [ __ ] vibes
um and then because there's no vibe in
their hotels they then have to create a
vibe
with uh with aquarium lighting or
whatever the [ __ ] it is they do over
there
all right funny robbery story um and
yeah the pizza place
it was very busy spot after the bar let
out because we had huge slices and were
open until 4am now i worked there tons
of employees came and went mainly
because it was really long hours
uh regular hours involved working 4 p.m
to 4 00 a.m
four to four wow
so one night
while working a dude came in
with a bandana on his face and he yells
at me give me all the money
while his hands is in his pockets that
look like he had a gun without even
thinking i say go [ __ ] yourself
[Music]
[Laughter]
and then he starts laughing
takes the bandana off and asks how did
you know it was me
apparently he used to work there but i
had no clue who he was
he took me it took me a second to even
recognize him after telling me this so
if this had been a real robber
i would have either just thwarted him by
standing firm or i would have got my ass
beat or killed
people there is no
[ __ ] reason
to ever get killed in a robbery on
purpose
okay
don't listen to these stories and be
like i want to have a funny story so i
can write into a podcast please do not
do any of this [ __ ]
um
especially if you're working 4 p.m to 4
a.m
slinging [ __ ] pizzas and hash
to a bunch of drunks anyways just
thought it was funny
i thought it was funny it's [ __ ]
legendary
just thought it was funny that i was so
pissed that someone tried to rob us that
i had no regard for my own safety please
tell me they at least gave you employee
of the [ __ ] month
give me all the [ __ ] money go [ __ ]
yourself
i don't even feel like i can you know in
honor of you i'm not gonna say go [ __ ]
yourself
because you already did it to end this
podcast
uh that is amazing so please keep your
uh
if i was a dictator things coming in
tell me your robbery stories because uh
these are amazing all right that's the
podcast everybody
uh once again congratulations to the los
angeles rams
sean mcvay all of those guys oh my gosh
so i i even forgot half the drama of the
game odell beckham
getting hurt
was having the game of his life uh
so great to see him get a ring
um 99 i forget his [ __ ] name i
shouldn't but i'm you know i got two
kids under the five and uh man i i don't
know anybody's names anymore he wreaked
havoc and uh he got himself a ring very
happy for them cooper cup all of those
guys um and like i said the bengals are
going to be a problem in the future they
just got to get an offensive line
um
i mean if they have an offensive line
they're super bowl champions right now
man it's just uh
so they are they are that [ __ ] close
and i know as much as bengal fans were
excited to get joe burrow in the draft
there's no [ __ ] way especially after
that knee injury you thought you were
gonna make it all the way
to the super bowl in just his second
year and not only that he beat the
kansas city chiefs that [ __ ]
juggernaut offense
uh he went toe-to-toe with them and that
defense stopped them
um in the afc championship game so
nothing to hang your heads about
uh but we've all been there
as fans
having your team lose the big one it
sucks but uh
nothing but
bright stuff in the future i'm not even
going out on a limb everybody knows that
um that is it
uh that is the podcast
you know what i usually say but in honor
of that guy making pizzas for 12 hours
helping all those people air quote sober
up
uh you guys have a wonderful couple of
days and i'll check in on you
on thursday